[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend Christian Otto zeigt uns
wieder mehr vom Erfolg der Bayern und
der alpinen Gold für Deutschland lange
sehnt guten Abend hier sind die Themen
an diesem Mittwoch
der Kranich bleibt am Boden ein
beschädigtes Kabel stürzt die Lufthansa
ins Chaos und legt den Frankfurter
Flughafen stundenlang lahm
Bilder aus einer belagerten Stadt im
ostukrainischen bachmut harren noch
Zivilisten aus während die Kämpfe weiter
toben
und Gold im parallelwettbewerb bei der
Ski-WM in Mary Bell holt Alexander
Schmidt den ersten Titel für Deutschland
seit zehn Jahren
[Musik]
heute brauchten sehr viele Menschen sehr
starke Nerven nämlich all jene die am
Flughafen Frankfurt Main starten oder
landen wollten wegen einer megapanne an
einer
s-bahn-baustelle vielen Flüge aus oder
wurden umgeleitet erst vielen die
Computer der Lufthansa aus dann wurde
der Airport ganz gesperrt weil sich die
Maschinen im Luftraum Frankfurt stauten
10000 Passagiere betroffen an der
Baustelle im Norden von Frankfurt
durchtrennte ein Baggerführer gleich
mehrere Glasfaserkabel Peter Theißen
über das it-chaos und die Folgen
lange Schlangen bis in den Nachmittag
hinein fast nichts gegen mehr nachdem
bei der Lufthansa die IT fürs einchecken
und bohren komplett ausfiel hunderte
Flüge wurden gestrichen wir waren schon
am Geld eigentlich in zehn Minuten
Einstieg und dann ist alles
runtergegangen genau unsere Koffer sind
auch weg deswegen nach Miami erst wurde
er quasi angezeigt als verspätet und
dann ist er jetzt leer nach Miami
geflogen ohne uns sozusagen erlebt
es hat nicht so toll Störungen weltweit
im Luftverkehr tief im Boden die Ursache
an der S-Bahnlinie 6 in Frankfurt bei
Bauarbeiten trennte ein Bagger dort
gestern Abend vier Glasfaserkabel durch
ich vermute dass die Firma die diesen
Baggerfahrer beschäftigt hat dass sie
zumindest eine gute Haftpflicht hat
sollte sie haben weil das ist ein
Schaden der geht ganz schnell in
zweistellige Millionenbeträge auch
Anschlüsse von Privathaushalten sind
betroffen bislang konnte die Telekom
zwei der Kabel wieder reparieren es ist
aber sehr komplex weil zum einen der
Schacht fünf Meter tief geht die Kabel
dort unten beschädigt wurden der
Kabelschacht gerade mal schulterbreit
ist das heißt da muss ja jemand runter
und dann händisch diese Kabel
miteinander zu verbinden immerhin am
Nachmittag gingen wieder erste Lufthansa
Maschinen in die Luft die Airline hofft
dass der Betrieb schon morgen wieder
einigermaßen normal läuft
wir gehen nach Frankfurt zum Flughafen
dort für uns Stefan Schlösser Stefan wie
ist die Lage aktuell und wie fällt die
vorläufige Bilanz aus
tja offenbar laufen die Computer Systeme
wieder zumindest teilweise der
Flugbetrieb normalisiert sich so langsam
aber diese Bagger arbeiten die haben
schon eine heftige Wirkung entfaltet
einige hundert Flüge sind ausgefallen
einige 10.000 Reisende waren davon
betroffen jetzt arbeitet die Lufthansa
fieberhaft daran die Folgen zu
beseitigen morgen soll der Flugbetrieb
so ziemlich normal laufen aber an der
einen oder anderen Stelle wird es
sicherlich noch ein bisschen ruckeln am
Freitag aber da droht neues ungemacht
die Gewerkschaft wäre die hat
angekündigt an sieben deutschen
Flughäfen zu streiken ein ganztägiger
Streik wurde da ausgerufen das bedeutet
dass an diesem Flughafen nicht besonders
viel gehen wird mehrere Flughäfen wie
Frankfurt und München haben bereits
angekündigt an diesem Tag keinen
einzigen Passagierflug durchführen zu
können der Flugbetrieb wird also mehr
oder weniger komplett zum Liegen kommen
also für alle Menschen die in dieser
Woche mit dem Flugzeug unterwegs sein
wollen alles andere als einfach
danke für die Schilderung nach Frankfurt
zum Flughafen Stephan Schlösser war das
für uns
kurz vor dem ersten Jahrestag zum
Kriegsbeginn verstärkt Russlands Militär
mit Unterstützung der berüchtigten
Söldnertruppe Wagner Attacken auf
strategische Ziele besonders dramatisch
ist die Situation seit Wochen im hart
umkämpften bachmut dorthin gelang dem
freien Journalisten Arnd Ginzel die
Fahrt mit dem Auto Christian Volk fasst
die Bilder zusammen
unterwegs auf einer der letzten Straßen
die noch nach bachmut führen für 30 km
brauchte seine knappe Stunde die Route
ständig unter russischen Beschuss viele
Militärfahrzeuge bachmut ist weitgehend
zerstört vor dem Krieg lebten hier
70.000 Menschen nun Haaren noch knapp
5000 Zivilisten in der Stadt aus eine
von ihnen ist Galia sie hat zu Hause
kein fließendes Wasser mehr muss es an
einem Brunnen abfüllen
es gibt keine Wörter die zum Ausdruck
bringen könnten wie schrecklich dieses
Leben hier ist
die Menschen in bachmut Wachen mit
Explosionen auf und schlafen mit
Explosionen ein doch viele wollen
trotzdem nicht weg
wohin sollen wir fahren wer braucht uns
dort auf uns wartet niemand hier ist
mein Zuhause hier ist mein Sohn begraben
die die noch hier sind helfen sich so
gut sie können hier kochen Sie warmes
Essen warten bis es draußen irgendwann
wieder sicher ist es gibt ganz
unterschiedliche Gründe deshalb die
Menschen hier in bachmut bleiben
einige wissen nicht wie es weitergeht
anschließend andere haben Angehörige die
sie pflegen müssen und von denen sie
glauben dass sie sie nicht so ohne
weiteres aus der Stadt rausbekommen
wieder andere haben Tiere zu versorgen
russische Truppen Rücken vor allem
nördlich und südlich von bachmut vor die
Stadt droht eingekesselt zu werden auf
beide Seiten kommen wohl entscheidende
Tage zu
ja es ist genau diese Situation die auch
die NATO zum Handeln zwingt das
Verteidigungsbündnis will im Osten sehr
viel mehr soldatenstationieren außerdem
forderte Nato-Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg in Brüssel dem Mitglieder
auf ihre Verteidigungsausgaben zu
erhöhen beim Versprechen
kampfpanzerlieferungen an die Ukraine zu
liefern ist allerdings ordentlich Sand
im Getriebe
das Protokoll beim Familienfoto der NATO
ist eindeutig damit man geschlossen
zusammen steht bitte schauen Sie 8
Sekunden in die Kamera
und dann ging es um die großen
Sicherheitsfragen denn der Krieg in
Europa verändert auch die NATO sie
rüstet auf und wird verstärkt Truppen
nach Osten verlagern
wir werden deshalb unsere Abschreckung
verstärken wir werden 40.000 Soldaten an
der Ostflanke unter NATO Kommando
stellen insgesamt will die Nato die Zahl
der Soldaten in hoher
Einsatzbereitschaft von 40.000 auf
300.000 erhöhen auch die
Rüstungsausgaben sollen steigen die Nato
will als Ziel festschreiben dass die
Mitglieder ab 2024 mehr als zwei Prozent
ihres Bruttoinlandsproduktes für
Verteidigung ausgeben Pistorius
unterstützt dieses Ziel auch wenn es
Deutschland bisher verfehlt hat
allein dem 2% Ziel annähernd zu wollen
wird nicht reichen es kann muss die
Basis sein für alles weitere wir sind
innerhalb der Bundesregierung in der
Abstimmung dazu das Ziel 60 modernste
Leopard 2 Panzer der Ukraine zu liefern
können Deutschland und seine Partner
nicht einhalten sondern es wird nur 17
geben
nicht alle Panzer die zugesagt werden
können sofort
transportiert werden aber ein großer
Teil wird Ende März bis Ende April in
der Ukraine sein können die NATO
arbeitet an ihrer neuen Strategie es
muss schnell gehen denn der Krieg
fordert das Bündnis heraus
ein Jahr Krieg wie kommen die Ukrainer
mit all dieser Gewalt klar die beiden
ZDF Reporterinnen Katrin Eigendorf und
Jennifer Gierke sind dieser Frage
nachgegangen dabei trafen sie Soldaten
an der Front Frauen deren Wohnungen
ausgeborgt wurden und Mütter die ihre
Familie verloren haben die ganze Doku
Leben im Krieg die können Sie bei uns in
der Mediathek sehen oder heute Nacht um
1 Uhr hier im Programm
falschnachrichten gehackte Accounts
Verleumdungen im Wahlkampf und all das
gegen Bezahlung um Wahlen zu
manipulieren oder Politiker zu
diskreditieren dieses Geschäft mit Fake
News bietet tatsächlich eine israelische
Firma an nach Recherchen von ZDF Spiegel
Zeit und weiteren internationalen Medien
hat das sogenannte Team horche Kunden
aus Wirtschaft und Politik Felix Klauser
und Armin Körper mit den Einzelheiten
sechs Monate undercover drei
Journalisten ist es gelungen sich
einzuschleusen in eine Gruppe die sich
Team hoche nennt sie sagt von sich
selbst dass sie in Afrika Asien und
Europawahlen manipulieren kann aber
offiziell gar nicht existiert
habt ihr gesehen was an der Tür steht
nichts kein Klingelschild kein Name wir
sind nichts
das Kerngeschäft der kriminellen Handys
Hecken und künstliche Identitäten
Avatare in sozialen Medien erstellen
die haben uns gezeigt wie sie Avatare
kreieren sowie ich mir eine Pizza
zusammenstelle
im August 2022 nach der Wahl kommt es zu
Unruhen
Manipulationsvorwürfe werden laut aus
den Verdeck gedrehten Szenen liegen dem
ZDF Hinweise vor das Team Roche hier im
Einsatz war
diese Recherche lässt uns zum ersten mal
sehen wie es hinter den Kulissen
aussieht erstmals sind es die Akteure
selbst die erklären wie sie operieren
die Gruppe offenbar seit Jahren aktiv
die Auftraggeber womöglich auch
Regierungen
nach Monaten gelingt es die Männer zu
identifizieren rohe heißt in Wahrheit
talhanan mit den Vorwürfen konfrontiert
teilt er mit um es klar zu sagen ich
weiße zurück dass ich etwas Falsches
getan habe
die Enthüllung ist Teil des Projekts
storykillers des investigativnetzwerks
vor bitten Stories dass die gravierenden
Folgen von
Desinformationskampagnen aufzeigen will
es ist das erste Mal dass es
Journalisten gelingt die Methoden der
Manipulation so offenzulegen
ja was ist konkret möglich bei der
Manipulation von Wahlen mehr Details
dazu finden Sie jederzeit in unserer App
oder auf ZDF heute.de etwa darüber wie
die israelische Firma bei welchen Wahlen
ihre Finger im Spiel hatte
die Folgen der Beben in der Türkei und
Syrien werden auch in Monaten und Jahren
noch deutlich spürbar sein vor allem bei
den Opfern und ihren Angehörigen im
türkischen Kachelmann Mara Schulten die
Helfer eine Frau und ihre beiden Kinder
lebend aus den Trümmern nach
228 Stunden hier und an anderen Orten im
Süden des Landes sind viele Menschen
traumatisiert in Antakya einer der am
schlimmsten zerstörten Großstädte der
Erdbebenregion war Britta Jäger für uns
Sie bitten und warnen die Suchtrupps
immer wieder bloß vorsichtig zu sein
wenn sie ihre Angehörigen schon nicht
mehr lebend wiedersehen sollen die
Bagger die Leichen wenigstens nicht
zermahlen wenn Freunde oder Familie die
toten Körper nicht sofort identifizieren
werden sie zu einem anonymen Massengrab
außerhalb der Stadt transportiert
deshalb beobachten Sie hier die bitteren
Szenen und warten die auch so her schon
seit Tagen
das ist so eine schlimme Situation wenn
du deine Lieben verlierst wenn Sie meine
rausholen werden wir Sie nach Syrien
bringen zurück in die alte Heimat
die Stadt am südlichsten Zipfel der
Türkei die für ihre Historie berühmt und
für ihre multireligiösen Bewohner
bekannt war ist jetzt nur noch ein
Trümmerhaufen mit am stärksten hat es
auch eine der Hauptstraßen Richtung
Altstadt getroffen hier waren die Häuser
schon vor dem Beben alt und marode
bewohnt vor allem von der großen
syrischen Community eigentlich teilt Ali
Bea sieht mit seiner Hilfsorganisation
Decken und Nahrung aus jetzt hilft er
mit nach Leichen zu suchen das letzte
große Erdbeben vor mehr als 20 Jahren
hat ihn abgehärtet ich habe öfters alles
mögliche gesehen was ein Mensch was ein
wirklich nicht sehen will aber jetzt ist
für uns sagen
leicht die Bagger arbeiten schneller die
schwarzen Säcke die für so viel Leid
stehen werden jetzt fast im Minutentakt
gebraucht und zwar an allen Ecken der
Stadt an takia ist am Boden buchstäblich
so können Sie die Menschen im
Katastrophengebiet unterstützen sie
scannen unten rechts den
QR-Code dort alle relevanten Infos zum
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe die
IBAN lautet
de65-100 400
600-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben
Türkei Syrien und all das zum Nachlesen
auf spenden.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf
der Seite 89.0
Beamte des Bundes die den Staat ablehnen
verfassungsfeindlich denken oder sogar
Handeln solche Extremisten aus dem
Staatsdienst zu entlassen dauert oft
Jahre wegen sehr sehr langer Verfahren
und das soll jetzt leichter werden durch
eine Reform des disziplinarsrechts
klausbruch dazu
es sind wenige Fälle durch jede einzelne
ist für das Vertrauen in den Staat
gefährlich deswegen will die
Innenministerin Extremisten und der
Bundesbeamten schneller aus dem Dienst
entfernen können wer den Staat ablehnt
kann ihm nicht dienen daher muss jeder
extremismusfall klare Konsequenzen haben
auch Polizeigewerkschaften und
Beamtenbund wenden sich gegen
Extremisten in den eigenen Reihen fasers
Gesetzentwurf aber lehnen sie ab mit
diesem Gesetzentwurf werden keine
Extremisten schneller aus dem Dienst
entfernt dieser Entwurf führt Ängste bei
uns Polizistin Polizisten insofern ist
er nicht geeignet sondern reden wir über
140 Fälle und das ist aber für die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen so als wären
sie alle erstmal mit dem Generalverdacht
belegt nach dem Motto unsere
bundesinnenministerin die oberste
Dienerin traut uns nicht der Entwurf der
Ministerin orientiert sich ein
Regelungen aus Baden-Württemberg die
dort seit zehn Jahren erfolgreich sein
sie selbst weiß die Kritik daher zurück
ob das ein Generalverdacht ist nein ist
es gerade nicht weil wir nur das
Verfahren beschleunigen also wir setzen
ja nicht andere Hürden an in der Frage
wann sind solche Fälle da weil es geht
immer noch um die gleichen
Prüfungsmaßstäbe die haben sich nicht
verändert einzige Ausnahme
Volksverhetzung soll schon bei
Verurteilungen zu sechs Monaten Haft zum
Verlust des Beamtenstatus führen bislang
gilt ein Jahr
nach der Wahl zum Berliner
Abgeordnetenhaus wurden noch mal
fehlende Stimmen ausgezählt es ging um
466 Umschläge von briefedern im Bezirk
Lichtenberg und konkret um die Plätze 2
und 3 hinter der Wahlsiegerin CDU
Ergebnis der knappe Vorsprung der SPD
vor den Grünen hat sich nach
Medienberichten noch leicht vergrößert
sollte es also wieder eine Rot-Grün rote
Koalition geben würde sie von den
Sozialdemokraten angeführt offiziell
wird das Resultat kommende Woche bekannt
gegeben
and the winner ist Halle an der Saale
dort soll das zukunftszentrum deutsche
Einheit entstehen ein Ort an dem
Erfahrungen und Erfolge ostdeutscher
Geschichte und Kultur sichtbar werden
sollen große Enttäuschung über die Jury
Entscheidung bei Mitbewerbern wie
Frankfurt oder oder Jena auf der anderen
Seite aber eben große Freude in der
Händelstadt Halle Christian
der Sonderzug fährt nicht mehr nach
Pankow Halle an der Saale heißt der neue
zukunftsort die 240.000 Einwohner Stadt
kann jetzt planen am zentralen
Verkehrsknotenpunkt mit ice-anschluss
soll das neue zukunftszentrum deutsche
Einheit und europäische Transformation
entstehen eine 200 Millionen Euro
Investition der Bürgermeister von Halle
ist überglücklich es soll ein Zentrum
sein wo man miteinander in einen Dialog
kommt sich austauscht über seine
Situation über seine Gefühlslage es soll
aber auch
wissenschaftlich arbeiten wie man
bestimmte große zentrale Themen angeht
für die Zukunft
Halle in Sachsen-Anhalt ist der
überraschungsieger die Mitbewerber
Frankfurt oder Leipzig gemeinsam mit
Plauen Eisenach und Jena sind allesamt
enttäuscht
das zukunftszentrum mit geplanten 200
Arbeitsplätzen soll die Leistungen der
ostdeutschen in den letzten 30 Jahren
hervorheben ziel ist ein populärer Ort
mit bis zu einer Million Besucher pro
Jahr auch die Architektur an wird
spektakulär sein das ist auch das was
wir als als Grundvoraussetzung für den
Architekturwettbewerb sind was genau und
das neue Zentrum kommen soll ist noch
unklar aber eines ist vielen in Halle
wichtig und nicht nur dort als ich mir
wünsche dass dem Bürger endlich mal
zugehört wird
Halle kann jetzt loslegen 2028 soll das
neue gesamtdeutsche zukunftszentrum
fertig werden
so Kristin jetzt kommen wir zu einer
forstigen Überraschung und die gab es
bei der alpin-wm Superding tut richtig
gut zum ersten Mal seit 34 Jahren wieder
WM-Gold für einen deutschen alpinen
Skifahrer in einer einzel-disziplin
Alexander Schmid bisher ohne Weltcup
Erfolg wurde nun Weltmeister im
parallelwettbewerb die erste deutsche
Medaille bei diesen Titel kämpfen
Lidl Strasser heute früh ausgeschieden
in den Armen des Goldschmieds der eine
zentnerlast von allen DSV Athleten nimmt
souverän gewinnt der 28-Jährige Allgäuer
alle Duelle im Kampf Mann gegen Mann und
lässt im Finale dem Österreicher
raschler roter Kurs keine Chance siegt
erstmals in seiner Karriere gewinnt Gold
das ist echt unglaublich ja Herbst
selber nicht erwartet und
unheimlich cool
zum ersten Mal seit 34 Jahren dominiert
ein deutscher wieder in einem WM
Einzelwettbewerb
ja nicht ganz so rund lief es diesmal in
Oberhof für Biathletin Denise Herrmann
Wick nach WM Gold und Silber reichte es
über 15 km zu Platz 15 die Sprint
Weltmeisterin Denise hermannweg heute
mit einem gebrauchten Tag insgesamt vier
Strafminuten stehen schießen halten mit
zwei mal zwei Fehler aber das ist mir
jetzt lange nicht mehr passiert umso
ärgerlicher natürlich das ist mir heute
passiert ist besser macht es die
Schwedin Hanna über 20 Schuss 19 Treffer
dazu eine schnelle Schlussrunde die
27-Jährige verdrängt ihre
Mannschaftskollegin in Person auf den
silberrahm Bronze geht an Lisa vitozzi
aus Italien beste deutsche heute Sophia
Schneider als 13 Denise hermannweg auf
Rang 15
und Fußball Champions League von 23 Uhr
an dem ZDF darin alles zu den bisherigen
Achtelfinal Hinspielen Borussia Dortmund
will nachher gegen den FC Chelsea sein
Heimvorteil nutzen und der FC Bayern
München hat bereits gestern Abend
vorgelegt ein verheißungsvoller Auftritt
bei Paris Saint-Germain Torschütze zum
1:0 sie Kingsley Coman die Bayern
dadurch mit einer guten Ausgangsposition
für das Rückspiel am 8 März auf
Kursrichtung Viertelfinale und Frankfurt
und Leipzig spielen erst nächste Woche
ein gutes Spiel danke Christi so wir
haben noch die Lottozahlen für sie und
die gehen so 19 22 26 33 37 45 und die
Superzahl 6 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
lotto.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Textseite
morgen sieht es nach Wetteränderung aus
denn von Nordwesten ziehen Regenwolken
auf dazu gleich mehr von Katja horneffer
wir empfehlen das heute journal um 21
Uhr 45 mit mariierter Slomka das war von
uns schönen Dank und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend wenn Sahara Staub auf den
Atlantik getrieben wird und auf den
Kanarischen Inseln die Sicht trübt heißt
das Kalima dieser Sahara Staub wird dann
ins normale Wetter Geschehen einbezogen
sie sehen das hier auf diesem
Satellitenbild von gestern und manchmal
kommt der Sahara Staub auch bei uns im
Mitteleuropa an für Sie hier mal orange
schraffiert morgen kommt also ein
bisschen was davon bei uns an vor allen
Dingen aber wird es morgen von
Nordwesten etwas Regen geben heute gab
es noch das übliche Spiel also entweder
Sonnenschein oder Nebel und der Nebel
löste sich nicht überall auf wie hier
z.B am Main oder auch am Mittelrhein und
an der Donau und jetzt in der Nacht
bildet er sich zum Teil wieder neu
gleichzeitig kommen aber hier im
Nordwesten schon die ersten Regenwolken
heran und die Temperaturen sinken auf
plus 5 ist -4 Grad die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 7 und 15 Grad und am Vormittag
regnet es dann hier so zwischen der
Ostseeküste und Ostfriesland sonst
geht's nach Nebel viel Sonnenschein und
da der Wind schon zunimmt sollten sich
die Nebelfelder Auflösen der Regen
erreicht dann am Nachmittag
facebookermark und auch das Sauerland
und dann wird es sehr wechselhaft und
stürmisch an der Küste am Sonntag wird
es merklich kälter tschüss